I first saw this pattern that I'm about
to show you in a question on the math
stack exchange what the user had been
doing was playing around with data in
polar coordinates the pattern that we'll
look at centers around plotting points
where both of these coordinates are a
given prime number it initially looks
quite random after all primes are famous
for their chaotic and difficult to
predict Behavior but when you zoom
out what you start to see are these very
clear Galactic seaming Spirals and
what's weird as some of the arms seem to
be
missing and zooming out even further
those spirals give way to a different
[Music]
pattern these many different outward
pointing
rays